hey guys and welcome to the final
episode of best LittleBigPlanet 3 levels
of the week
who are we I'm cam this is said you did
it first Tyra style big mess a little
bigger 3 levels of the week professional
yeah you're very very good at that
yeah it is the final episode this is
episode 4 of the show that we are making
in partnership with Sony where we check
out the best of your digital creation
set chums so thank you for all of the
ones who provided thus far can we pick
the ones this week I have I got given
the keys to the to the creative King
though and I've picked three one is
really good two are kind of weird and
let's get to the first one so the
sticking out so it's become a bit of a
theme where you guys every time I played
this you've dressed you basically
bullied me by dressing my character
various bits and bobs well give me nice
to me this week it's a final week it was
going to be nice eight drummers drumming
no no no that's a giant drop me I almost
stuck that on myself pencil it I'll drop
on the drum okay
well give me a pencil skirt okay tinsel
beard there we go Christmas wouldn't be
Christmas without a lump of coal I think
we are Christmassy enough we're ready
well done young sab this is the amazing
mountain and the river it's there Matt
kindly tells me it's letterbox is this a
movie we're playing no no this is not an
actual level so this level is quite
tricky but it's really well-made now can
you figure with to here yes you can
good job okay move the wall uh-huh very
good very good
it's isn't this uncharted okay okay how
about spikes yeah we both don't good
despite my tinsel got in the way the
game is struggling to handle my giant
snare drum head which I don't blame it
for really one we drum on the back
apparently I don't yeah it's good it's
drum cheering Joe the kids will call
embarrass myself chin would you hurry up
very good whoa here we go some
exceptional platforming Oh No well the
worst
human did that happen oh yes good Oh
keep going you got it you've got it
don't do what I did he is king and
champion don't do what I didn't run off
the edge
every now and then it just kill these Oh
like this oh yeah yeah
Beth deaf again I'll take you for it
why don't want you just raise it up and
then I can just yeah there we go
really we're cheating slowly we are not
cheating this is how you is how you
little big planet this game is about
creativity cam and I think what we're
demonstrating on here you need to let be
my eyes set and then let me jump no no
don't turn it good god you're killing me
there we go alright and then what
happens when you network I don't know
think it did did it I think haha okay
yeah we're the best at this game
oh god John I'm the worst of this game
why did you kill me um because a life
without me cam is no light at all it's
like a digital marriage can don't die
thing
drowning me cat demonstrating you're
drowning me in love we're showing you
what not to do I am committed to this
relationship right I got it
yes my love this collateral of did
conquer it now oh yeah we're too good at
this pretty deep so it's all kicking off
Oh be sure to grab damnit or we can do
survive come on she's really good okay
sure feldy Val D more lightning down the
point slide 50% job like that glitter
man win I'll take that I blame the drum
in my face hit you in her back my
victory can help you back accept that
was the amazing mountain and the river
by rambu 20 Thank You rambu 20 yeah well
he loves used to a hard levels' he knows
the jungle
rambu always need a jungle I said this
next one is traffic panic and this is
like a pasture controller type deal okay
so you've got control of one so I'll let
you oh I see what it is you can feel
most of the panic yeah you go so the a
shamanic you're controlling the traffic
you control the traffic lights all right
push any button to go and try to avoid
the other checkout Bristol right trigger
anything maybe yeah Oh every car you get
through oh that's easy
yeah this isn't exactly the same as real
truck ah I like this guy maybe that's
what the problem is like you're sending
cars through and what's gonna happen is
a cyclist is gonna arrive at your lights
and just sail past lights anyway and die
I feel like mine are a little harder
yang oh wow oh that's a shame premature
relation when he was that I think we see
what the problem is I think you need to
be my eyes cam okay I can be my eyes
beer guide me guide me all right so what
are you looking close go go over the
little God man go hold it hold it oh
stop stop stop stop stop
hold it down you can't just press it ah
EDI easy to kick so that was your fault
okay on great okay I'm never gonna work
here you killed so many people cab on on
on get ready for green rain that's good
Nasri nailed it okay
green green nice red bud Oh what guys
nipped through there this is good this
is good okay you ready Green bring
Brad's breath yes okay it's fine we made
it we made it okay green yeah that's you
stay agreed yeah all right okay green
haha no I tried to get that guy third
poster score green let's go let's go
hahaha that's 850 dude those good okay
all right I think you do better though
one more one more one more
safe driving promotes a crime god oh god
no Green Green Green Green Green I
didn't see green anyway
Green below the government they go red
right I just show yourself
I just so I saw it in a hedge I got a
lead foot care green very good driving
everybody
yeah Green Green oh it's so close we
went for it oh my score though great
score
good job everybody good I think we made
them more fun with addition of green red
I think what we've done is we've created
the game all right
that's not the game this is the game
this is the game all right
that was good traffic panic by TARDIS
build on Titusville or Todd is Bill who
knows who knows okay so this level is
called PlayStation experience wipeouts
white one player only okay I've quit out
give me another head-to-head style
exactly a little wipeout car are - yes
oh nice
he's quite wise gear digger was really
drifty oh it's very draining very brief
shot earlier it's quite hard and it's
very easy to die it's a very micro
machine Z Oh wrong way around
spin it round do I get do I get
power-ups I feel like I need a speed
boost speed boost would begin oh great
drifting wow goes faster in corners
oh it's getting very wet life life cling
to life oh dear oh no you've ever shot
it clung to life
oh maybe not you're still going winning
we can if you ever play wipeout Sam it's
look like you do you do yeah that's the
game where you crash into things
deliberately right I know yeah yeah well
duh no oh no and and liner and life I
think that know there's okay okay Oh
nope that's that's the roads yeah yeah I
think you should keep going off I've got
I'm finding my own room oh oh no have
the route with that no there is death
that way oh yeah I guess it's three laps
three laps now how did I do any of your
time
nice no lives longer I see if I'll see
what I can do then I said no lives lost
space Road okay you're better or better
in games around a real driver ass indeed
oh god oh god times you crash the killer
Oh what are you doing stupid car aah
oh yes points for everybody together cut
together I think the shortcut is off to
the right of this bridge of death
No Oh No well easy come on off to the
right now yeah there you go there's your
shortcut it is she was a shortcut all
this
yeah yeah oh I think you did better on
it cheetah god damn it no I lost aah
well except that it would me
well considering you didn't get a score
off that the fact that I guess you
didn't lose a life in Queens
but let's just say you didn't crash she
fine I didn't okay totally crap you
didn't fake three much but that was the
PlayStation experience wipeout byte
vex'd awful dealer thanks Beck salutely
make me lose again so what was the final
score uh okay so the first one you won
the first game you had I did we drew the
second one because working together
is it a draw because you know it could
really use this win can really win this
win for this so that's gonna gonna sway
this way all right I think it's really
good I'll let you win well before we get
to that we still have the comments from
the last episode okay Cameron I'm gonna
feel these to you rates
I mean Lucy last week so Mac as best you
can rest and red X Archer 24x says
LittleBigPlanet 3 was a fantastic game
kind of short but all quality never even
started any maker levels yet though oh
well really should yeah this is the time
to do it I guess there's lots of content
on there that is going off so
unfortunately we obviously can't
showcase in this show this is the final
episode you know if you make some let us
know anyway and yeah we can maybe let me
share it to the rest of our followers on
Twitter there's tons in fact there's the
the team picks section of the community
levels which means that the guys who
made LittleBigPlanet presumably go in
and design all the best kind of stuff
it's their choice this is like you know
the designer is go ahead and they find
their favorites secondly we've got Danny
man who says I'd like to make a flappy
bird level with swoop that's great I'm
pretty sure someone's ready made that oh
really I'm sure it must exist I have
seen it I'm sure if I haven't I make it
because that's a good idea yeah that
would be a pretty easily put death on
the top and death swim-two-birds and
then and and make the obvious spikes as
well totally I think that yeah
everything on fire next one is multi
loco loco lock right gray name black ops
bomb survival was hilarious in the first
and second one perhaps it's also in the
third however check it out it probably
is I mean I've played some of the bomb
survival games before in the previous
and they were really good fun you have
to showcase one last week which is a
special one for also it I was really
good
I think odd sock works quite well with
the mom smile because you can use easy
here it's easier to survive yeah
even though we were still nervous yet
here are you guys such peace knows
actually okay it was more me all right
Juan Marquez says I like the show but it
kind of annoys me when they put a bunch
of clutter on their characters well I'm
sorry well that would be love
well yeah that's for you we did we did
remove some of it this time and put a
downside yeah but it's time camp for
this or that this or that Isis are very
special this for that because it's a
clincher for you
it is a clincher you nail this ice eyes
off the price eyes off surprise okay
alright the last one not looking at
final episode this or that everything we
had land ready here we go ready Cameron
yes station of play or Michael Bay
Michael Bay l1 r1 or r2 d2 r2d2 burlap
or power nap
Briella Epic Yarn or epic bond with Epic
Yarn hug community or drug immunity from
Dorian's is variable therefore that jump
or glide right a belt or slide slide
show or hide sure blast a handle or
master vandal last night span a face or
Santa's place span of face accessorize
are excessive lies exact on it says our
lives
arcade or user made okay PS gray or PS
navy astray mistletoe or missile whoa
missile will and finally back sack or
crack I'm gonna go for sack because of
sack way very case said that was very
good yeah I went for my slightly festive
yes I know I noticed a few like
Christmas ones in there yes I think yeah
I think that was pretty great is that
okay
even though accessorize or acceptance or
lies did made me grown and dial it with
side I still I still think he's okay
give you the win I'm gonna take you out
just because you've yet to have a win I
feel like I feel like it'd be cruel me
to hug all the winnings I deserve I
deserve that
I deserve this cam that brings us to the
end of the final episode of best Little
Big Planet 3
of the week which was your favorite
level I think my favorite overall I
think mine was the motor bikes
motorbikes was good although that was
technically a little big planet one
level that have been adjusted for
LittleBigPlanet really enjoyed the
fighting one that we listed last week
that was I was terrible
you were very very bad that was really
fun although wasn't really like an stand
a little big planet format those are
really yeah but really ingenious way
visa - it was like the sort of Rock'em
Sock'em program I also really enjoyed
the we did today the first one the a of
their mysterious amazing mountain then
the river yeah I like that as well I
love those kind of levels especially
when they're that difficult well sab
that's it for the show
all dreams must die good things come to
an end and even this show the show say
yet there are other dreams we were wrong
the show doesn't always go on then I
think Oh is a Shou end this show is that
is today that is vie goodbye well it's
goodbye from me said let's go back me
cam okay and it's also goodbye from
Lucy's as well yes you know because she
won the last two it was ultimately the
best it was three of us it's very kind
generous even for her to give runners-up
which is why she's not here yes but if
you'd like to tweet us with any levels
that you've made another big planet 3
please do Cameron how are they to you
oh they cute Wheatley at Camp Fraser ah
how about you sir I'm at Ready Steady Go
and you can sweet Lucy she's at least
games game yes good then we've got the
yeah but um as we say if you do finding
levels that you like make sure you let
us know and you can always hit us up on
Twitter yet but until we speak again
thanks for watching